do you fill out a bracket Ian I didn't
do a bracket but I did do one of those
not obviously for money but I did do one
of those pools with my high school
buddies where you do kind of a snake
draft and you pick eight teams and and
all that so I'll be watching how much
money is at stake there oh that's right
you said there's no money of course you
don't
we play for pride you can see the NFL
Network's NFL free agency frenzy at
10:00 a.m. Eastern right clue us in on
the biggest move so far was made by who
I would say obviously the biggest money
is Kirk Cousins we know that's gonna
happen later today and that's it's a big
move quarterback is incredibly important
to me though I would say the Giants made
the biggest move with my anger
you know Nate's older it's not a it's
not a skill guy Bobby says I would see
two of them I'd say the Giants and
Chiefs the Chiefs signing Sammy Watkins
for really means a lot of money 16
million a year but a big-time playmaker
downfield for Patrick mahomes that is
all offense is going to be exposed so I
think that's one but then the Giants
getting sold I mean it's not a skill guy
it's just a tackle but most you know
second most important position on the
field making sure you I doesn't get
sacked a million times and running for
his life like he was last year
swiping one from the Patriots and the
Texans that was a huge move for Pat
Shermer in the Giants who did better at
the quarterbacking position this past
week the Browns of the bills
uh I would say probably yeah that's
really tough because I think the Browns
did fine they got themselves an
absolutely viable good decent starter
who is 500 that's what his record is
Tyrod Taylor gave up a lot first pick in
the third round but for the bills that
story hasn't been written
I mean AJ is probably going to be agent
McCarran is probably going to be the
starter there but them trading Courtney
Glen who played decent to them last year
but has been battling foot injuries then
trading QWERTY Glen and moving up nine
spots in the draft to put themselves in
position to take a quarterback and move
up again in the draft was like the
underrated and most fascinating move of
the whole week you know because you know
they found AJ last night for two years
ten million which is nice I don't know
what he is but they're definitely are
smart football people who think he's
going to be a legitimate pretty good
starter in the NFL but the bills moving
up in the draft was really clever
following the model of the Eagles from a
couple years back that was a cool move
but if you're looking at the number of
teams who are still going to draft
quarterbacks Buffalo gets McCarran
Denver gets Case Keenum Denver Cleveland
has got Tyrod Taylor are all three
drafting quarterbacks and then I would
have the Jets - I'm not 100% sure of the
drafting quarterbacks they are
absolutely positioned yeah I would say
my guess right now let's assume that all
these quarterbacks are ranked as we pick
right let's assume they're all ranked to
the top five or top ten I would say the
Browns probably take one in either one
or four I would say the Broncos probably
take one at five I would say the Jets
I'll go 50/50 on whether they take one
the Giants I don't know it looks you
know everyone sort of thinks they're
going to take one but it would be so
Dave gentlemen to take like a guard at
to the best guard prospect we've seen in
10 years
Nelson say yeah yeah I've we got Baker
Mayfield coming up next our how did this
protego
so I'm like it won well I mean the
reviews were good and look I mean he's a
good football player I don't think
anyone cares about like him running
around in shorts there was more about
the what he was like how he interacted I
mean all the reviews I got were positive
it was like Lego kind of went like we
thought I think what's interesting about
Baker Mayfield is you know I feel bad
for him a little bit because he's always
going to get the Menzel questions
because he's a little kind of fiery dude
who runs around and wins a ton and has
crazy stats and you know had the arrests
and obviously so it's there's some stuff
there it seems like he likes to play
football a lot more than Manziel bit I
mean I loved watching him at the CN
Scouts and GM's did too watching him at
the Senior Bowl run around full of
energy he was getting everyone kind of
going you know watching how fast he goes
about his business and kind of the the
way he does it was really instructive
just about like what kind of a football
player he's gonna be I think from the
people I've spoken with the impression
he's made so far has been really really
good what do you make a Gronk's tweet
for Danny Amendola who left to go to the
Dolphins where he emphasized in capital
letters happy and free what cryptic but
is there something there that's all that
it's not nothing I mean I'm not gonna
pretend it's like you know it's just a
social media like people send messages
on social media now so it's it's a thing
it was a hard year in New England there
was a lot of tension it was and I think
everyone felt it from from Tom Brady to
Gronk to Danny Amendola and all of that
I mean it was it was a difficult year
you know Bill Belichick is the best
coach in the history of sports I think
or at least getting there and it's hard
I mean it's it's not always the easiest
experience and I would say there
certainly are people who want to go out
and be freer and be themselves and be in
a different environment I would also say
that Danny Amendola leaving was not
about him wanting to be free it was
about him getting offered more money he
got a really really nice contract from
the Dolphins that you know is going to
pay him more than the Patriots would
have paid remember
came back to the Patriots for like three
years in a row taking pay cuts so I
think this was his first and last
opportunity to really get paid Jimmy
Graham in and Green Bay Jordy Nelson is
Allen how big of a surprised was that
where is he land
you know for me not really a surprise on
Jordy Nelson I'm you know he's a 33 year
old receiver who was making ten billion
dollars ten million dollars against the
cap so I would you know to me those guys
are always in jeopardy and you know the
same thing like let's say he he's he's
still in Oakland right now visitin went
really well he hasn't left yet so that's
a really good sign as far as maybe they
end up signing but then it's like bring
him and his salary in maybe that means
Michael Crabtree needs to go so I think
it's always sort of that you take one
big salary you replace it with another
as far as Jimmy Graham I'm still mind
blowing a little bit by the Packers
spending money and free agency and going
out and B I mean they made a trade this
year
they made a tricky like a real trade
with players and everything and picks
players and picks were both involved
this is a new Packers and I'm stunned by
that I am also going to be really
interested if they get it right at the
Ted M position this year which obviously
they didn't last year Aaron Rodgers
really needs that and dhama can sue it's
released and I saw a couple of teams
Seattle was one of those teams for him
where does he end up yeah I think
Seattle's probably a team I would think
are definitely a team they've been
looking for defensive tackle help it's
really just a matter of like how much
money is he gonna need to play you know
he's made 120 million
so I'd say financially he's probably
going to be okay you know
is he willing to take six or seven
million a year which is probably what
are eight maybe eight let's say eight
which is probably what those defensive
tackles make now or is he going to need
twelve because I'm not sure anyone's
going to give them 12 million a year
that guys don't really want to pay for
you know
ten twelve fourteen million dollars a
year for defensive tackles who don't
rush the passer and aren't Aaron Donald
that's a really hard thing to do I'll
leave you with this the fan base that
should feel the best today is who oh
that's a good one I would say the Browns
probably mainly because they always feel
so sad it's so sad there and what
they've done this offseason has been so
interesting and clever I mean the
tie-rod trade like I knew they were in
the mix but I did not know until you get
to click text that it's happening that
was a good one
Jarvis Landry you know a premier
productive receiver you know they they
lose Joe Thomas obviously but they know
beefed up the tackle position I got a
number one running back they're still
doing the work they have a great front
office and a ton of ticks who now they
know how to use them I think the Browns
should feel pretty good ones have fun
today Ian we appreciate your time I
don't know about fun but always enjoy
being on with you thank you guys that's
Ian Rapoport NFL Network insider you can
see him on the NFL Network's coverage of
free agency starting at 10:00 a.m.
Eastern for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]